all right get everyone hope you guys
have been having a good NDC good
conference so far before I get started
just a quick show of hands how many of
you got Isis the bulk of your production
workloads running on the cloud right now
all right cool and what about your
running in your own data center how many
have you got majority of his stuff
running in your own data center all
right good all right probably a bit of
half-and-half
my name is Mahesh Christian I work for a
company called the AGL energy it's based
in Melbourne Australia and yes that's
right so I've come all the way here to
do a talk it's a long way to fly it's a
long flight AGL energy obviously we are
in the energy business we not only
generate electricity we also you know we
also sell gas and electricity to to
consumers in Australia and we run a lot
of our infrastructure a lot of stuff in
the cloud I probably you know we I would
say that we're probably one of the
largest consumers of a sure within
Australia it's of one of the largest
consumers we run things like our SAP
workloads and everything else in there I
have been working in in the cloud from
the very early days of azure of being an
azure and maybe for a few years a number
of years and I've been very passionate
about building highly resilient
applications that run on the cloud so we
knew when you run your applications you
know in terms of when when it fails it
doesn't really affect the application
application continues to run and things
like that it even in the event of
failure the topic the talk I'm gonna
give today is titled architectural
patterns for the cloud but the
interesting thing is that whether you're
running your applications in the cloud
or in it's a distributed application is
running in your own data center you will
find that all the the patterns that I
talked about is still relevant to you
however as you will see during the talk
it becomes even more relevant if you're
running in the cloud the agenda is
actually pretty simple I'm gonna talk
about some of the guiding principles
based on which you know
the catalog of patterns of picked up our
and I'll run through a series of
patterns there are about 21 patterns
that I'm going to talk about today right
so the the emphasis is more on breadth
rather than on depth of the pattern so
in each and every pattern I'll talk
about what is the problem that's
actually trying to solve how do you
actually fix the problem how do you
solve the problem and then some
considerations so hopefully it gives you
enough to make you dangerous right so so
hopefully you know when you go back to
work and then use come up across a
scenario where you need to use these
patterns you'll dig a little bit deeper
and then start utilizing these patterns
itself so as I said there are 21
patterns so I would suggest that you
hold on to your questions till the very
end so I've run through the you know my
presentation and run through it and I'll
wrap up with a few links that you can
actually use when I said deep dive so
you know you can actually follow those
links and get more information about
these patterns itself so let's talk
about some of these guiding principles
what does the reason that most people
move to the cloud and primary reason a
lot of people cite is the power of the
you know the to leverage the power of
the seemingly infinite cloud right so
you've run your workload and if you want
to scale you know lots of people
visiting your site and things like that
you can quickly scale scale up scale out
whatever you want to call it quite
easily without having to worry about
running out of hardware and so on I said
seemingly infinite because sometimes you
can actually run out of space even over
there right but to do that a lot of
cloud providers there are certain things
that come out of the box right so you
can earn multiple instances and they'll
give you load balancers global load
balancers that will allow you to kind of
look distributor traffic equally between
all the instances and so on and so forth
but you still need to make sure that
your architecture your applications
appropriately to make use of this of you
know the scale that it actually provides
so if you've got a big monolithic
application you kind of like need to
break it down into smaller components
and you need to start to decouple these
these these components once you decouple
these components then it makes a lot
more sense you can start to scale these
things independently you can start to
isolate them
and if some of these things fail they
don't start perfect other parts of the
system itself so so that's one of the
things that you need to start thinking
about the second reason that people want
to move to the cloud is that you know
it's it's a lot cheaper a lot cheaper
than the average data center that you
run your current workloads on and the
reason it's cheap is because the cloud
is literally built on you know commodity
hardware hardware that's a lot cheaper
than the expensive ones that you put
into your racks in your data center so
they are more prone to failure than the
hardware over there so you know they
even talk about things like mean time to
recovery that's more important than the
mean time to failure which is what a lot
of these Hardware typically you know
state in their specifications and so on
so that sucks the first thing the second
thing is of course you know the cloud is
massively multi-talented right so you're
running a lot of a lot of other people
are sharing the infrastructure sharing
the same resources that your
applications are running on so you could
have your application could be really
well-written behaving really well but
you know you could have noisy neighbors
who literally you know spoiling the
party that you're actually having right
so you know they start to eat up into
your resources and so on and cause
failure so that's another reason for
failure and again you've got distributed
applications so when you have
distributed applications you can chances
are some of the the downstream services
they have actually failed and so what
does that mean to you right so you have
no control over these applications that
they're that they're failed so the basic
thing here is that failure is imminent
right in the cloud and rather than avoid
failure you've got to start to embrace
failure and you start to start thinking
about you know I spoke about how you
start to put things into components and
so on so when failure does happen you
want to make sure that you have a
limited blast radius so it doesn't
affect some of these other services and
so on it's going to be one of the key
things that we want to explore and
failure when failure does occur you want
to make sure that you you you degrade
for me as well so that's another key
thing that you want to think about never
send a human to do a machines job this
is one of the quotes from the matrix
it's one of my favorite movies and you
know it's very appropriate to use it now
and you know when we are deploying our
applications and so on there used to be
a time when we would you know have a
planned outage you know you said well
you know we've got a window of about two
hours and you kind of like give your
build scripts to deployment scripts to
someone and they would actually go ahead
and deploy it you know click cops you
know do a bunch of things to deploy the
application and if it succeed it's good
but if it fails and it takes a lot more
time to kind of like roll it back you
can't do those things anymore right so
you want to have automation you want to
automate everything so not only do you
want to automate your build pipeline and
everything else
your whole deployment needs to be
automated you want to have zero downtime
deployment you're all talking about high
availability and you can only do that
when you're automating all those things
but it doesn't doesn't stop there it
just doesn't stop when you deploy your
application you want to make sure that
nothing goes wrong over there you want
to have good monitoring over there and
good alerting
so when something actually goes wrong or
is about to go wrong you are notified
you're alerted that something is gonna
go wrong and then you can do something
about it I would wait why do you need to
do something about it right so again
it's a human over there say what you
need to do is to to make sure that the
machine takes control of that as well so
you have a whole bunch of self-healing
and everything else built in all of that
is automated as well you want to build
for performance and responsiveness in
this day and age where you know the span
of attention of people is very very
short even a few milliseconds can cause
people to you know be impatient and then
go over to another another site and you
know there's a loss of sale and
everything else that all the citizens
will show that you can actually map and
how slow their responses and how it
starts effects ails and things like that
so but certain things just do take a lot
of time to do so how they actually solve
this problem and you do this by running
things asynchronously
so the customer still gets a good
experience but you can actually take a
lot of the you know the work offline and
do do these things asynchronously the
other thing is that you want to start to
optimize for speed while I did computer
science in university you know we
thought about things like how you need
to optimize for for storage space and
things like that you know you talk about
things like data bases and normalization
and so on and so forth but now storage
is cheap you can create multiple copies
of your data store it in different
places and you know that makes if it
makes you up or for a your machine go
faster you an application go faster so
be it
and I put a little asterisk over that
right so it's still kind of like it
depends on the situation you don't want
to be in a situation where you're just
ridiculously creating more and more
things and you're blowing out your cost
so you still need to keep an eye on it
but in most cases that should be fine
and again you want to start thinking
about latency and bandwidth if you are
running in the old days like
client-server applications you know the
client and the server they're all we're
in the same network and that you could
have really chatty calls you know going
back and forth between your client and
your server and was all okay but now in
a distributed environment when you have
like an is like your your services your
API sitting somewhere else and your data
sitting somewhere else some of these
these high chattiness can actually kill
your applications they can make it so
slow that's totally unusable so when
you're designing these things you want
to start thinking about those things as
well last but not the least you also
need to deal with legacy applications I
mean a GL we run a lot of SAP you know
workloads and so on and again we have a
lot of modern applications you know the
and so you still have your legacy
applications like SAP and you have your
modern applications your web apps your
AP is and Microsoft's and everything
that you've built and they still need to
communicate with each other and not only
that in some cases some of the the
workloads recited in
in in your like on-prem while your you
know your modern applications are
sitting in the cloud so you need to
start thinking about that as well so
we'll talk about some of these patterns
that addresses a lot of these things you
know how you deal with things like
legacy applications and your modern
applications and so I've categorized the
patterns that we want to talk about into
into five separate areas we'll talk
about available T patterns what happens
when you know how do you make your
application highly available even in the
event of failure and so on what do you
data management patterns you have a lot
of these days you know data is cheap and
storage is cheap and we end up producing
more and more data so I will look at
some amount of patterns to deal with
some of those things I will look at
design and implementation patterns I did
talk about things like legacy
applications talking to your cloud
applications we'll look at some of those
patterns that address that we'll talk
about performance and scalability
patterns as well and then finally we'll
finish up with resiliency patterns what
how do you deal with with failure when
things go wrong how does the application
deal with it so let's talk with
available let's start with availability
patterns right I mean we talk about
things like high availability you want
to make sure that the application is
running all the time and you can achieve
a lot of these things quite quite easily
right I mean there are certain things
that you can get out of the box with all
the cloud providers you can run multiple
instances like I said earlier and you
can put a you know set a load balancer
in front of it and if you want to if
you're using databases you can have
replication you can create multiple
copies of your data and you kind of like
get some level of high availability but
that's not enough in most cases so there
are three patterns that I want to talk
about the first one is your health
endpoint monitoring so when we talk
about you know SSL lace and things like
that the one of the key things a problem
that we want to fix is that there's a
need to ensure that applications are
running within the required SSL ice so
how do you address this thing what you
do is you build functionality within the
application itself that starts to to
check the health of the application and
then you expose this through endpoints
and so an agent sits over there and then
it kind of like hits these endpoints
frequently it is
you what the status of the application
is and and starts monitoring now there
are certain things that you want to
think about when you're building your
health endpoint itself first and
foremost you know how do you start to
expose like this one endpoint that goes
in and checks all the different things
and I did all the downstream services
that it actually connects to or or you
know you you kind of like have multiple
endpoints that can actually you know for
each and every one of those
functionality right do you want to do
like a you want to do like a shallow
hill check or a deep hill check a
shallow health it could be like a simple
pink writes over the source up and
running a deep one could be looking at
you know all these other services that
actually talks to and then sees whether
they are up and running as well you want
to start thinking about the frequency in
which you actually want to do your
health check how many things do you do I
mean like you don't want to be in a
situation where you're constantly
hitting your health service endpoint and
you're kind of like bossing yourself
right so you know you want to avoid
things like that you have an agent that
is monitoring it what if the agent
actually goes down so who monitors the
monitor right so that is those are
additional things that you want to think
about the next pattern I want to talk
about is around this this pattern called
load leveling using cues and one thing
that I did mention is that there are
certain things that are just slow it
takes a lot of time to execute right so
when you have a let's say you have an
endpoint like an API endpoint and your
client talks to it let's assume that it
takes a long time to finish the
operation that it wants to do so
literally what happens is when it hits
the endpoint it's just waiting for this
thing to finish out and when it's
waiting it just holds up valuable
resources and then when you have heavy
load and a lot of these turns are
actually waiting that starts to create
problems performance and reliability
problems actually start to to come up so
how do you actually solve the problem
well you you solve the problem by
actually having a queue and and doing a
lot of these things asynchronously now
I'd like to it kind of like explain this
with a non-technical example right let's
say you want to
and apply for a permit so you go to your
counsel you know you're making some
changes to your house you go to the to
the council and you submit a form so
they've got a window over there and the
person sitting over there and you can
actually go and submit the form right
it's fine
so you go and submit the form it takes
the person some amount of time to
process all the form and get back to you
and while it's happening all you're
doing is waiting over there right sets
waste of resources on your part they
just sit over there stand over there
waiting for the other person to complete
it and then someone else comes along and
they want to apply a permit because
you're holding it out right and they all
he needs to do is get in line and now
he's waiting even longer and then
another person comes in and suddenly you
have like a like lots of people waiting
and until my job is done this cannot be
processed right so what if they actually
turn it around a little bit and then
they have like a tray right in front of
it all you need to do is to go and drop
your item in the tray and you can
actually go away right so your time is
not wasted and everyone who actually
comes in can actually drop their forms
and they can go on their merry way as
well and you think about it right so you
can also do this thing even when the
council is not open so you know the tray
is sitting just outside the window so
you can actually use the same analogy in
this in this scenario right so what
actually happens is whoops too far
so what happens is the client who calls
the API endpoint the API endpoints
whatever task it needs to do it's a
long-running task
it creates an item and it puts it into a
queue a worker thread over here a
command processor picks up this item and
then process it or process it offline
asynchronously it can take a long time
to do it that's fine you know it does
this stuff it writes your database and
so on and so forth it's all fine
if there's a number of items in the
queue actually increase you can actually
start to scale this you can actually
have more processes that are doing it
you know the same analogy you know if I
extend the analogy if if there are lots
and lots of application form sitting
over there
I can have another person start to
process some of these forms as well
right so in this scenario what actually
happens is that if for these these are
durable queues if something actually
goes wrong hitting the wrong button
if something actually goes wrong over
here and there's a failure the item goes
back into the queue and you can actually
execute it or an or again so you got to
be careful so that you can actually
start to think about things like I don't
put in C over here what it means is that
when you're executing the same task
again you want to get the exactly the
same result
let's say you are doing a like a wire
transfer right and you're halfway
through the wire transfer and there's a
failure and the whole system breaks down
so what happens is the item goes back
into the queue and if you execute the
same item again you don't want to deduct
money from the same account twice right
this is where you need to be careful and
you need to think about item frequency
going back to the council example right
so let's assume that there are hundreds
of forms that get delivered to the
council every day and but you know
whatever reason you you didn't do yours
on time but you want to you're prepared
to pay extra right so you want to pay a
hundred bucks to make sure that yours is
done quicker the council will happily
take your money and process yours first
right so that's probably separate tray
for that where you can actually pass out
so the same thing applies over here you
can actually start to set up priority
queues and based on the priority queues
you can actually start to pick a pick
the pick the ones that
are more important and then process them
ahead of time so so you can actually
have a whole bunch of hues over here and
then depending on the function that you
want you can post the to the right cue
the command processor can actually pick
it up in the next cuter and of course
you know the command processor can be
scaled independently so you see more and
more items queuing up over here you can
actually start to scale it so all those
items get done done quickly but every
now and then in spite of doing things a
synchronously there will be plenty of
there will be a lot of load on your on
your server and there will be a point
where you have so much load that it's
starting to cost performance and
reliability issues so how do you
actually fix this right so what you need
to do see you you kind of like start to
monitor your resource utilization and
when your resources listen you start to
set some thresholds and when it reaches
those thresholds what you want to do is
firstly what you want to do is you want
to disable some of those non-essential
services so you can actually free up
some resources between your your server
and then you've got to start rejecting
new requests coming in that's no two
ways about you start to reject those
DUHS requests because it is more
important that your service doesn't fail
then you know rejecting some some new
recruits that are coming in but I didn't
you know you do other things like you
start to defer some of the non-essential
tasks as well but the key thing to keep
in mind over here is that throttling is
always a temporary measure so what you
do is you start to reject these the new
requests that are coming in but while
you're rejecting it you want to make
sure that you do other you put other
things in place so you know like things
like auto scaling or things to to make
sure that you know the
you can start to process more requests
and things like that once you do that
then you can actually you know get rid
off of the throttling itself you also
need to keep in mind that when something
actually goes wrong and you're rejecting
these calls you are returning the
appropriate code back to the calling
client one of the patterns I'll talk
about is a retry pattern right what the
retry pattern is when something actually
goes wrong we basically say hey you know
it maybe it's uh you know transient
error just try again right you don't
want to be in a scenario where you are
experiencing a lot of load and you're
rejecting the service and the client
actually thinks oh it's temporary and
I'm gonna call this person again call
the service again and it starts to
compound a component the problem as well
so making sure that you return the
appropriate codes the client can
basically you look at it and you're like
okay well you know there's something
wrong with it
I will hold back for a while before I
try my operation again and you also need
to think about how we you know how you
perform graceful decoration when some
other unit throttling and things like
that happen how do you how does the the
client handle so these are things that
you need to think up front before you
start your the whole application Nowell
architecture itself well then let's talk
about data management patterns like I
said you know in this day and age we are
generating lots and lots lots of data
right data is king and even if we don't
need the data we just collect it anyway
so that we can maybe use it in the
future which is okay there's nothing
wrong with it right but it come in a lot
of other problems that we need to to
deal with so I've got about six patents
over here acacia side materialized view
CQRS Valerie and I'll go through them
one by one starting with the acacia side
pattern now casing is actually a really
good thing so when it helps with
performance in a rather than go to the
data source every time the case is a lot
faster than let's say a relational
database so you go to it get the data
and and you know you return back the
data back to the client it's really good
but what it actually does is that at
some point in time the case data gets
stale so you've gone and updated the
data source but the case is still
holding on to old data and then you have
all these data consistency issues so how
do you actually solve this problem
the way you solve this problem is is
effectively let's say that you have
let's say you have you know API endpoint
you hit the API endpoint looking for
data it goes to the cash purse and say
hey do you have the data that I'm
looking for and you say well I don't
have the data I'm looking for so you go
in to the data source get the data and
when you get the data you check it back
into the data cache right so that's
that's that's okay that's all good
the subsequent calls will always find
the data in the data education and then
it's quick right now what happens is
that if you want to update this data
over here that is the main data source
you always go to another API endpoint or
the same UPN whatever it is you go to
this API endpoint and when it updates
the data in the case it invalidates the
sorry the updated data in the data
source it invalidates the case over here
so what it means is it removes the item
from the case so if you're looking for
the data again where you go and you'll
find there's no data in there and you
know you need start from scratch you
know you go back to the your main data
source you get the data and so by doing
this your data isn't stale so it's
always the most recent copy that you
have you can do certain things like you
can improve the performance by actually
priming the case so when you start the
application you can actually load data
from the data source and check it into
the case so you know the first time it's
not empty so you can do things like that
to improve your performance even further
the one thing you need to think about is
that most cases sometimes the case is a
lot smaller than your actual data source
so you still need to think about hey
what happens with you know how long do I
hold on to this thing lifetime of the
case data itself you need to start
thinking about that you want to start
thinking about data eviction policies so
if the if data is there in the case for
a very long time you know maybe you want
to get rid of it or you know you need to
come up with policies that handle that
well the one thing that you need to be
careful off in this thing is like
someone coming in directly and updating
the data source over here say in which
case then you still have the same
problem that you originally started with
so you end
but still they're over here materialized
view is an X pattern I want to talk
about when you're going and looking at
data itself right like I said typically
in most cases we're still storing data
in a relational in a relational
databases a relational database so you
have multiple tables and you do you know
joins you do group bys and all these
kind of things and this is generally
quite slow the second thing is if you
want to do calculated fields I'll go
I'll give it an example of something
from my industry energy right so one of
the things that we do at at HDL is you
know we have all these smart meters
right so the smart meters basically show
you collect usage information about the
electricity that you've consumed and
they keep sending back data every 15
minutes so you can actually look at it
and say well hey you know how much is my
consumption you know in this hour or
this day this week and so on and so for
you can actually get all the all the
data you can actually look at it but
here's the thing right so we the the
meter data is always in thing in units
like kilowatt hours or something like
that a user doesn't understand what that
unit is really they want to know in in
dollar amounts how much they've actually
consumed and so there's a lot of complex
calculations so you know they could how
like the price could be different
between the certain time periods and
people could be in different prices and
you need to kind of like calculate all
these in the fly and rather than
actually calculate this on the fly what
if you pre calculated this and created
materialized to be over everything
resides over there and that will
actually make you know make it really
performant so the way to fix the problem
like I said is is is effectively you
create separate views based on the
specific queries and you can do a whole
bunch of this you know combined
calculated fields you can do
transformations you do all of the stuff
and put it in a separate view and say in
this example right so you've got this
complex data you know you do your
complex you know group buys and
everything else and check it into a
materialized view and whenever you want
data you just get it directly from you
you just remember that this is a
read-only view of the data itself right
so when if you want to go change the the
data you still need to go and update the
source data
oh here so things that you need to think
about is like you know how do you
actually deal with trigger mechanism
when you update this data how frequently
do you start to update this and when
does it get triggered and how do you
update this you want to start thinking
about you know storage cost blobs if you
start to creating lots and lots of
materialized views the data is complex
in this large and how do you how do you
deal with it most of the time it's not a
problem you know like I said you know we
we do a lot of these things ourselves in
a at HDL so we create a lot of lot of
views even usage data so uses data that
that's there for every 15 minutes and
and so on so it all works it's not it's
not such a big problem a lot a lot of a
lot of cases the the materialized views
are are you can sort in transient stores
you know you can store it in a cage and
you can literally blow it away and then
recreate it whenever you want
so works are quite well the one thing is
when you want strong consistency that's
still a problem you know you need to
figure out you know the materialized
view may there may be a bit of a lag
between the time this is updated and and
you see the results over here so you
need to keep that in mind it's kind of
like an extension of the materialized
view itself right is the right you know
there's a bit of a mismatch between
reading and writing data but what we
generally do is is we kind of like run
them through like a standard like a
business logic and they all go through
the same flow and when you're writing
data what happens you put locks on the
down the on the table itself or you know
on the records and that leads to you
know locking and you know it slows down
the reads and so there's kind of like
this mismatch right so so the CQRS
pattern actually solves this now I've
been talking about secures for a long
time and maybe out five six years ago
when I even asked the question like how
many people know about this and you know
hardly you know quite a just few people
in the audience who put their hand up on
casa christian again how many of you
have heard about this pattern and use it
yeah see the nice thing about it is like
a I see a lot more people putting their
hand up and starting to use this pattern
so how does this pattern work like
literally what you do is you separate
out your reeds which is effectively a
queries and your commands which is
affecting your rights and and so you
kind of like use this the the query
centric work for the Q centric workflow
pattern that I was talking about right
so when you are doing your commands your
rights you check it into a queue and
your command processor or your worker or
here picks up this item and it
asynchronously writes to the database
and it can be a really slow operation
but you don't care right so it
eventually makes a lot of these changes
and it writes to the to your data source
and and then you can still do a bunch of
calculations and create your
materialized views over here so when
your when an application wants to read
the data it just goes in and just goes
to the query the data is actually
appropriately shaped for it so you can
actually go and say hey get me the data
and then takes the data and it's it's
you know it's so quick and it's it's
really performant so even with this
design you need to you know you could
you have to deal with things like this
eventual consistency issues that I spoke
about earlier
so you still need to reckon with that
but this is this is a this is a pattern
that that is you know extremely popular
these days
and there are a number of things that it
actually provides right even when some
of the the nice thing about it is like
even if some some parts of system
actually fail for example let's say the
command processor fails right and the
database is not available whatever it
may be you can still start putting items
into the queue and then when this system
is up it can actually pick it up and and
and and then process it and you have
this materialized divisible here right
so even if the system is down you can
still have your reads and they can still
continue to work so you kind of like
introduced a lot of resilience into the
into the architecture itself the next
pattern is the valid key pattern that I
want to talk about and in a typical
application when you want to access data
let's say you want to access a customer
data right so what do you do you go and
go to an API and say hey can you get me
this customer data it
over the database it grabs the customer
data and then gives it to you right so
the API would actually do security
checks and everything else and it's all
fine but what if you're dealing with a
different kind of data so let's say
you're dealing with something like a
streaming data let's say it's a video
images or audio meters or the data
itself is so big rights like like large
documents and so on so in this scenario
what really happens is that when you
when you have many are calling the API
to get the data from the data source all
that does is it goes in streams all the
data loads it up and then it passes it
back to the whoever is asking for and it
starts to consume you know compute and
other resources and things like that
it's probably in the long run it's not
it's not a great way of doing it but you
also don't want the client to go
directly to the data source because you
want to have you know you want it to be
secure and so on so so the way to fix
this problem right so you effectively
end up the client ends up going to the
cloud application and say you know can
you please give me a token to access the
data right so it gives a time-limited
token which actually expires and so you
go directly to the data service and then
you know you give it to add the access
token and this token is actually called
a valet key so you give the valet key
and since I can I have the data and then
the data is directly streaming between
the service and the client and you don't
have to have an someone sitting in
between they're actually basically reads
the data and pass it back there are
certain things that you want to think
about in this pattern again you know you
need to kind of like manage the Valatie
period of the key you don't want the
Valatie period to be too short then it's
too short then you know you got to start
requesting for this valet another valet
key again and that's not efficient and
you don't want to make it too long
either because in that case you know you
have like a rule key running around
you're worried about you know misuse and
things like that this is not suitable
when you are doing some kind of
transformation with the data itself
let's assume you know it's probably a
bad example but let's say you have
let's say like a video right so like a
colored like a and you're converting
into black and white and passing through
right there's a transformation you're
doing on-the-fly and those are the kind
of scenarios where it's not applicable
what you should really be doing is you
should be creating a copy of it in like
black and white and storing it right and
but yeah it's a kind of like an
extension of that is the static content
hosting now I kept in data patterns
content I also treat content as such as
data so in this scenario let's say
you're you've got a single patient so we
do this at at HDL we've got an
application called my account it's it's
an application that allows you to
self-service right and it's a single
page app it's written an angular so what
does it contain it contains HTML it
contains typescript JavaScript CSS files
images and all those kind of things now
typically what happens is a lot of these
things are hosted in a web server and
all the web server does is it goes and
grabs the resource from your file system
reads it back and pass it on to the
client right that's a way stage of you
know the the web servers resources and
compute and everything else because all
it's doing is it's reading getting it
passing it back to someone else so what
if you actually served all the static
content directly from you know rather
nitrous served from the web server you
basically so extreme you know you know
you basically serve it from your storage
service things like your blob and so on
so in the case of my account what we're
doing is we're actually directly putting
it into the CDN so so that's that's even
better so you know you you you chuck
everything into the H service and
because it's only HTML and CSS and
things like that you don't have to worry
about things like you know security and
things like that right we still run our
API isn't everything else and that's all
hosted in the server and the suicide you
know you still need your web service to
actually process that but at least you
don't waste valuable resources in just
hosting static content
there are certain things that you need
to think about you know obviously your
deployment model and everything else
changes now so you need to figure out
how you do it there are certain things
like you know when you're using let's
say you chuck all the stuff into blob
storage the URL pot can look very
cryptic so how do you map it to how you
do your routing and all that you need to
figure out but it's it's not a it's not
it's not too complex you can actually do
that the next pattern I want to talk
about is sharding I keep talking about
this thing right so you you're creating
more and more data these days and which
is good but when you have large data
stores you kind of start to introduce
some limitations of the system itself
you know limitation in terms of storage
space your computing resources and
they're all stretched because your
database is now too big so how do you
solve the problem you solve the problem
by actually splitting the data into
horizontal partitions or shards right
and then and then you distribute it out
and so when your application actually
wants to do you to use certain type of
data it just goes to that chart and it's
a lot more easier to process that rather
than have a really large database so
things you need to think about is like
what is charting strategy is a lot of
people basically go and say well you
know we're going to base it on the
customers zero no fair
prepare the geolocation where they are
and then we'll shot it based on that
some people will basically say you know
a to a to D is a it's a shot and then e
2 H is another shot and so on and so
forth
whatever works for you right there's no
really good rule on saying this is the
right shouting technique but you need to
make sure that whatever it is you can
you can partition it appropriately right
so it's kind of like equal across the
multiple shots so the data is split up
equilibria in multiple shots when you
have shots you want to make sure that
you avoid queries that span multiple
shots as well that'll literally kill it
I mean so you want to avoid that at all
cost
things like reference data and you know
they can be shared across all these you
know they can be duplicated in shared
across all these shots so even if you
want to do
like joints and things like that they
all work quite well let's move on to
design an implementation patterns this
is where I want to talk a lot about you
know you may have legacy code legacy
applications in your system and but you
are now building modern cloud
applications how do they actually talk
to each other and so on what are the
patterns that are involved there are
about nine patterns and but we've
already seen covered a couple of them
we've covered things like CQRS and the
static content hosting so we will talk
about the first we will talk about the
rest starting with the Ambassador
pattern when you want to start talking
to you know cloud services and so on you
may want to introduce a lot of there's a
lot of cross-cutting functionality that
you want to have things like retries and
you know circuit breaker patterns and
things I will talk about in a in this
talk and when you have legacy
applications it's really hard to go and
change these legacy applications to to
build in a lot of these things in every
call that it makes so if you want to do
retry logic in it it's really hard to go
and change the legacy application so
that every call that it actually makes
is you know it's got creature logic in
it for example so the way you actually
fix the problem is you you end up
putting a proxy that sits between the
legacy application the remote shows so
every time rather than actually call the
cloud service directly you call the
proxy the proxy typically the Ambassador
and and the Ambassador a terrifically
the the proxy it handles things like
retry logic circuit breaker if you want
to do things like monitoring and logging
all of that stuff gets done over there
and then you call the remote service of
course you know it introduced things
like latency overheads you know you have
impact of generalized server features
for example you know in some cases you
don't want to retry right but now you're
calling generalized functionality so
you're forced to use retry so you can
you can fix a lot of these things by
having passing the context to the proxy
so the legacy application can pass them
some context so it can decide whether it
wants to do things like retry and so on
this pattern is uh is also is generally
implement as a sidecar pattern I'll talk
about the sidecar pattern I'll cover
that in a bit but just something to keep
in mind when you're writing cloud
applications you know you kind of like
green fields when you start from scratch
and you kind of like do your
domain-driven design you come up with
this really nice clean architecture and
data models and everything else but then
they want to talk to legacy applications
and legacy applications you know you
have these outdated data models and
protocols and everything else and so
what happens is to talk to them you're
clean model now we kind of it gets
corrupted because you need to kind of
like I had these data fields and things
like that you didn't really want to do
right so how do you actually protect
this so what you do is you create this
this anti-corruption layer that actually
sits between it's it's a facade that
actually sits between your legacy
application and your modern cloud
application right and this still has all
this clean design and everything else
and but when it wants to talk to the
legacy application it calls these
methods you know this functionality in
the anti-corruption layer the
anti-corruption layer has all the glib
ugly bits in it right it does all the
transformations and everything else it
converts you know there's this nice data
structures into this bad data
certificate that and then it calls these
legacy applications and the same thing
can happen over here so the
anti-corruption layer literally protects
this thing it's pretty useful when
you're migrating really large legacy
applications into the cloud and there's
this a pattern called triangular pattern
we'll talk about this in a bit and it's
kind of like that will actually help you
figuring out how the permanency
decisions as well like how long does the
anti-corruption layer remain and when do
you need to get rid of it and things
like that
back and forth front ends or BFF is a
pattern that's kind of like become
prominent since you you know we've
started having micro services and things
like that it's become more and more
prominent so you know the backend
services right so I'll explain what is
the back
services tend to be very generic so you
kinda have this have this nice clean
domain model that exposes all your data
so you have like a customer data and so
on or your product you kind of like
build all these kinda like generic
services back-end services that exposes
your data but then but then you have
your front ends and let's say you have a
mobile front end and the mobile front
end when it needs to go get this data it
needs to maybe call multi we need to
make multiple calls to get the data in
in in the shape and size that it wants
to actually display and so on you know
you've got a desktop web application you
can only needs data in a certain format
so to fix this problem what you do is
you create a specific you you create a
separate back-end service for each and
every front-end so in this case you've
got a BFF for mobile application and you
have a BFF for a desktop client
application what this mobile BFF does is
it can actually start aggregate some of
these services it may call the customer
service it may call the product service
you know it kind of like gets all the
data together and then it passed ships
it in in the structure and shape that it
wants and and sends it back to the to
the mobile application this is
effectively an implementation of a
gateway aggregation pattern which is
effectively what has an X pattern on on
the screen is so you know the problem
this is kind of like an extension of it
right so what happens is that there are
applications that want to call multiple
services to get some functionality done
so in this case like you know you know
you want to call services a B C and D
and this generates a lot of traffic so
you got to call multiple services but
you don't need all the data that's
coming out of each and every one of the
services you only want a subset of this
data so what you do is like if you were
to do this in your client application
there's a lot of traffic that goes back
and forth for a ready little data that
you really need right so what you do is
you create this this gateway aggregator
over here that aggregates all the data
together and
then pass it back to the application now
this application this pattern is only
works when the Gateway aggregate that
the aggregation gateway sits closer to
to all the others all the downstream
services otherwise you still have the
same problem that you originally had
right there are certain things that you
need to worry about one is you have all
these patterns like a B C and D or the
downstream services what if a B and C
are successful but D is not what do you
do in those can scenarios right do you
completely fail the whole service or do
you start to you know you know how do
you handle those kind of failures of
course the aggregation gateway can be a
bottleneck you need to think about in a
single point of failure how you address
that there's another pattern called the
gateway routing pattern except for the
term gateway in it they're very
different to the you know the the
previous pattern that I spoke about the
gateway routing pattern think about this
thing where you have multiple consumers
right off of a certain of a lot of
downstream services and it's really hard
to when you have a lot of consumers and
you have a lot of services setting up
these service endpoints to cater for all
of these in these consumers is actually
quite hard and particularly when let's
say one of these Stanko
particularly when let's say one of these
services actually changes you don't want
to be in a situation where you're
changing making changes on all the
consumers because you know this end
point is actually changed or the
structure of this exchange you don't
want to be in a position where you go
and change multiple consumers example
could be let's say you have an email
gateway over here right and you decide
to change your email gateway provider
and so let's say assume you have
multiple consumers over there rather
than go and make the scene is in all of
them all you need to do is change the
gateway router right and and not worry
about not worrying about changing any
and making changes in the consumer now
of course you know this does kind of
like introduce latency in the system
there's another level of indirection
another you know it needs to go through
this and then go through the go through
the actual service so there are certain
things but you know you kind of like
balance out the advantages with the
other problems that you get with it as
well a sidecar pattern is this is the
one that I actually mentioned about
earlier now this has become quite
popular in the last couple of years
particularly the rise of containers and
things like that so what is the problem
that it's actually trying to fix and
let's say you take the example of you
have you know you know you like you have
a lot of cross-cutting and functionality
with any application things like live
retries and so on that I actually spoke
about earlier right now when you have
those things you what you do is you end
up creating a library so you can
actually use the library and then using
the library you you make calls to your
system right so let's assume that you
create a new get package it's great you
know your dotnet code Dolf works but
what if your application is written in
Java suddenly all of that becomes
unusable right so what you end up doing
is you you implement and run these
shared services as a separate service
like that and it's it's sitting isn't
the same host so you have your primary
application and you have the sidecar
running in a separate process within the
same same container if I can call it
that
and when I do this right so what happens
is you know there is a bit of inter
process communication that happens
between these two things and but you
know this can be written in a completely
different languages can be Java this can
be dotnet and you can still work and
it's kind of like resembles like a
sidecar and like a motor byte and hence
the name as well like I said it works
really well with containers this is a
strangler strangler pattern that I was
talking about earlier and so when we've
been assigned to migrate these old
legacy applications into into into new
applications right there may be a lot of
other applications that want to talk to
the to the new application that is being
migrated a lot of this doesn't happen
overnight so you kind of like need to go
through a lengthy process when you're
migrating your old applications to the
new so how does how does it work how do
the other applications work with the
sample with you know the application
that's being migrated so the way you do
it is you create a strangler facade and
so when you first start with the right
this is your modern application and you
have this legacy application over here
you end up calling the strangler facade
and that redirects traffic depending on
that that knows whether it's now you
need to talk to a modern application or
you need to talk to the old legacy code
it decides and then it kind of like
redirects the traffic and over a period
of time right this gets smaller and
smaller you know you kind of like start
to strangle the legacy application and
then it eventually dies and so every all
the calls end up going to the modern
implementation itself and the key thing
over here is like you know when do you
kind of get rid of this facade because
they're kind of like added the latency
in to a system right if you design your
system well and the strangler facade is
kind of like a representation of the
modern application you'll literally be a
we should be able to swap out the
endpoints over here and it should just
work when you
all the workloads through so let's
quickly talk about some of the
performance and scalability patterns the
good news is that if you look at the
list we've covered all these patterns
you know use this case slide CQRS
materialized views and so on and so
forth
so we can literally kind of like skip
through this thing and then go over to
resiliency patterns right so there's
about seven in here but again we
probably covered some of them already
like you know the health endpoint
monitoring is already there load living
is already covered so we got about maybe
but four or five more patterns to go
through let's talk about the bulkhead
pattern so what happens is that when
you're when you are hosting an
application like a cloud application you
kind of like and there's a lot of
traffic that actually comes through and
like I said failure is imminent right so
when you have failure you want to make
sure that you want to isolate some of
this failure and you do this through the
use of bulkheads so if you look at ships
and submarines and so on what they do is
they they have these bulkheads built
into them so even if there's a breach
and there's a leak or whatever it is
they can completely seal off but like
one of these bulkheads and although you
know there's water that's actually
coming through one it doesn't affect the
rest of the ship so acts in the same
same principle over here so what you do
is you partition your services into into
groups right and you can actually think
of it recognizing the best example to
explain this is let's say you have like
a premium subscription you know you have
paid uses and you have like a free
subscription right you can start to put
all the paid users into a certain
bulkhead and then you have the rest in
like in other you know bulkheads and so
on so even though you get a lot of
traffic in in the free subscriptions
that still doesn't affect anything in in
in in in the in the premium subscription
bulkhead right Amazon in uses you know
what they call ourselves to implement
bulkheads functionality so you know you
could have like your load balancer and
your
you know application and your data all
in one cell and you know there's you
know there's something goes wrong
only that cell is affected so then they
deploy it across multiple cell so each
and every cell is literally a bulkhead
so failures in one cell
they're completely isolated and don't
affect the failure and other ones other
cells retry patterns it's probably the
first pattern that I should've talked
about right so the key the thing though
is that like I said transient errors are
quite common in the cloud and so when
you do get transient failures the first
thing you need to do is to check whether
it is a transient failure so if it is a
transient failure then you want to try
again and most of the times it's okay so
it'll succeed right but if it doesn't
succeed then you may want to wait a
little bit and then try again and so it
works works up quite well so every cloud
application should have a retrial logic
built into it now there are certain
things that you want to think about
right so one is like how many times do
you try before you give up so maybe it's
not a transient error right so it's a
more permanent error so so you need to
basically have like a certain number of
cria of retries you do before you give
up and then you don't keep trying over
and over again so that's it's a bad
thing it's like this thing where you
know you call up you know your partner
your spouse or whoever and say you don't
want to convey an important message you
pick up the phone I mean you you dial
her number and she's not picking it up
you may think oh you know maybe you know
maybe she didn't hear then the phone the
first name maybe you know it took a lot
you know it's hidden the person where
took her time you literally sometimes
call again right and it made you me
succeed but it doesn't pick up the phone
for the second time you kind of like
have a little bit of back off you back
off for awhile and then you call again
right so the same thing applies over
here so exponential back-off is the
preferred one so you kind of like wait
for a while and then you kind of like
double it and then you again doublet and
and then you wait but what happens is
that let's assume there are a number of
calls that actually come into the system
and they all been rejected because of
some some kind of failure and they all
have exponential back-off and they keep
hitting the server back at the same time
and suddenly you know when the system is
up and running you get all these these
these calls coming back at the same time
so what you need to do is you need to
start to introduce things like jitters
into their back off algorithm so it kind
of like introduces randomness into the
system so when you go back and call the
service you know they're not hitting the
service at the same time extension of
the retry is like the circuit breaker
pattern right so at some point in time
you need to give up and when you do give
up you and so when you do when you do
give up so the you know you need to stop
hitting the service or Noor again so you
stop this you know the circuit breaker
literally is is taken from you know like
electricity in the house right I mean
when you have a shot in the house for
example the system trips and the sacred
breaker you know comes into play so
there there are literally three states
to the sacred Riccar the closed state
when current is flowing through or you
know all the calls are coming through
that's the closed state that's the
normal state but when you do retry and
after a certain amount of time it
actually fails it it basically triggers
the sacred breaker and it's an open
State at that point in time current is
not flowing or calls aren't being made
but when calls aren't being made I mean
that's not the end of it right so every
so often you need to go back and see if
it's working again that's like the half
open state so when the half open state
you still make a call and the call
succeeds then you you continue on the
thing about circuit breaker right is you
should always have a fallback that's the
that's a better way of implementing it
rather than saying how you know what the
other service isn't working I'm just
going to you know throw up an error
message or you know do a graceful
degradation or something there rather
than that right you need to have a
fallback you know the the the the
example that I give is let's assume that
you've got a road right you got a manger
and all the traffic is flowing through
it but there's some kind of an accident
that's happened rather let more and more
vehicles go through you have kind of
like you know you have a stop sign over
there in the
then you don't let any more vehicles go
to right but that's not enough you need
to have a detour so the detour may
actually take you longer to get there so
in this case right there you may want to
display cash data rather than actually
going to the real data source and
getting the data so but it still
continues to work it may be a little bit
slower but I didn't hate it like this
it's working right or if the data may be
slow its stale but it'll still work so
every now and then you start to let a
few more cars go through right if that
car succeed in getting through then you
can actually open the main main road for
all traffic right so you kind of like
need to follow the same principle in
some cases you may want to consider
about accelerated sacred braking so you
know I spoke about things like
throttling when tackling is there you
don't want to you know you basically
don't want to retry it you kind of like
break the secret right away and running
pretty close to my time so this a couple
of more patterns to go a compensating
transaction is is you know when you have
databases right one of the things of a
nice thing about databases is you know
acid the acid in nature so you can run
everything in a transaction you can run
multiple calls and you you know all
these calls can you can commit them or
roll them back at the end of the
transaction right it's great however
when you have distributed systems right
and some of these could be long-running
holding onto these resources in terms of
a transaction is really a bad thing so
rather than actually do transactions
right so you kind of like do inserts and
do updates and things like that and you
have compensating transactions where you
kind of like undo the operation that you
just did that's a much better way so
let's say you you know you put our money
into someone's account and there's some
kind of failure you know you kind of
like the next step is not to undo them
you know it's not to kind of like you
just reverse the operation you go you've
taken some money out you know you put
the money back or you know you kind of
like have this composite of transactions
actually do it much better way and you
know it doesn't lock up any of the
resources and you know you get good
performance and everything else of
course you know you know you need to
think about things like I didn't put
into consideration if you do the same
again what happens all those kind of
things need to be taken into account the
scheduler agent supervised departments
kind of like an extension of of this
right and so when you have when you have
multiple steps that you actually perform
and and so rolling back is really hard
right so what you do is you do this by
having these three you know you have the
scheduler agent on the supervisor the
scheduler is is what arranges all the
steps that need to be done and the agent
basically contains a logic that needs to
be executed and supervised and basically
monitors to see hey you know if there's
any failure in any of the steps that's
happened right if there's failure any of
these steps then what it does it
actually does cause the compensating
transactions through the through the
appropriate agents and if you think you
know this this this sounds complicated
well it is right it's not it's not
trivial it's it's harder to implement
and so on and so forth but you know you
do get that advantage based on that now
that's kind of like you know it's just
like we just right on time it's quite
quickly recap yeah we did go through
about 21 patterns all up it's not that
you're gonna use all of these things you
know from day one you know you've got to
use what is appropriate for you and so
on and you know your mileage may vary
you know some how you implement them
there's no strict rules about some of
these things that actually said but you
know when when you do when you do come
across situation you know you at least
an income kind of like know enough about
it to actually dig a little bit deeper
and to dig a little bit deeper there are
certain resources that you can actually
use there's this book called cloud
architecture patterns came about five
years ago is was written by a fellow MVP
bill it's actually quite a good book and
then you have this this book the
designing distributed system some more
recent book that's actually come out it
talks about a whole bunch of patterns
and power and paradigms it even talks
about things like you know there's a lot
of things like containers that that's
kind of like new and now that was not
there in in Bill's book it talks about
things like citecar partners
example and how it all works and this is
other book this came out last year cloud
NATO development patterns and best
practices again it talks about a number
of those patterns that I mentioned today
in this talk right but one valuable
resource is this thing over here this
Docs dermaxyl calm as your architecture
patterns the structure and the grouping
of the the patterns and everything else
I picked up from that site it's actually
quite a good resource I highly recommend
going through that and of course you've
got the Amazons have got their
architecture website it's got a lot of
white papers in there highly recommend
looking at reading through those white
papers really good last but not the
least if you want to implement all some
of those resiliency patterns you know
retries and bulkheads and circuit
breakers and things like that there's a
library that you can actually use it's
called poly so so again highly recommend
the in fact there was a talk on poly
yesterday was a last talk yesterday I'm
not sure Danny after you go to that one
yeah a few people so again I highly
recommend you know looking into inter
poly if you want to implement these
patterns that's all I had I mean if
you've got any questions we've run out
of time but I'm you know I'll hang
around for questions you can always
email me or that's my twitter handle my
education you can even ask me questions
in Twitter
make sure that you fill out you know the
feedback on the way out green would be
good but you know if you got further
feedback and I'm happy to hear as well
right thanks
[Applause]
all right thank you these are get from
the